there weren't the big crowds but the
presidential inauguration was still
star-studded with the perfect powerhouse
trio
leading the way no matter what side of
the aisle you were on yeah i got a
little emotional i have to say
a lot of people do yeah i think so
because their voices were soaring high
above all the restraints this land
is your land
this land is mine
for nearly three minutes j-lo in
all-white electrified the dignitaries at
the capitol she sang a medley of two
songs
this land is your land and america the
beautiful and added one of her own
lyrics
[Applause]
in the morning spirit of inclusion jlo
also recited part of the pledge of
allegiance in spanish
[Music]
a-rod in the audience posted this image
of j-lo's assigned inauguration
seat the couple also shared this moment
with former presidents obama and clinton
and jlo paid tribute to the national
guard protecting the ceremony
taking a selfie with them yesterday
outside the capitol
eight minutes before jlo lady gaga
stepped out on the capitol steps for a
rousing rendition of the national anthem
[Music]
gaga held a golden mic and wore a golden
dove carrying an
olive branch she tweeted this morning i
will sing to the hearts of all people
who live on this land
gaga beamed when it was over and hugged
boyfriend michael polanski
and like a true country gentleman garth
brooks removed his hat before his a
cappella version
of amazing grace
how sweet the
sound at one point he even turned it
into a sing-along
i think i asked you to sing this last
verse with me as one
united uh
and tonight it's celebrating america a
90-minute
multi-network broadcast hosted by tom
hanks the latest ad
[Music]
katy perry who shared this pic of
patriotic microphones
justin timberlake will perform there's a
night at the end
and so will john legend one day
when the glory comes his wife chrissy
teigen has been loving all the
inauguration buzz
i am like a kid on christmas baby
she shared video of what appeared to be
a rehearsal provided live commentary of
today's inauguration it's happening
and lost her mind when she spotted j-lo
and a-rod
from her hotel window breaking news it's
j.lo and a-rod
finally i got you something now when it
comes to inauguration fashion the
statements came in all shades
none more powerful than purple
the new vice president harris and former
first ladies obama and clinton donned
the color choice
it is seen as both a symbolic bipartisan
mix of republican red and democratic
blue
it is also one of the colors of the
women's suffragette movement
and a nod to shirley chisholm the first
black woman to run for president
harris's coat was designed by a young
african-american designer christopher
john rogers
she accented the look with her signature
pearls which is an homage to her alpha
kappa alpha sisterhood
mrs obama's suit with a raspberry hue is
from one of her go-to designer sergio
hudson
a source tells et expect kamala harris
to be wearing that same designer
later today e.t also has this sketch of
first lady dr
jill biden's outfit which was also
custom the ocean blue
overcoat and dress is by marcary
and leave it to the celebrity performers
to make their own patriotic
red white and blue fashion statement
lady gaga brought the red and plenty of
drama in this custom schiaparelli
couture gown
this land was made lady in white j
lo wore head to toe chanel and garth
brooks well
of course he kept it country in blue
jeans
and all eyes were on the youngest poet
ever to read an inauguration poem
22 year old amanda gorman love
becomes our legacy gorman wore very
special accessories from oprah
these diamond earring hoops and bird
cage ring were gifts from ladies
in honor of legendary poet maya angelou